curiosity stream is the world's only
streaming service dedicated to
documentaries featuring tons of amazing
titles you won't find on any other
streaming platforms get curiosity stream
for 25 off which is just 15 bucks a year
by clicking the link right underneath
this video
all right let's start today with a sort
of comprehensive covid update you know
last week i told you that coveted cases
were
down in the united states on average
about 20 percent per day from their
delta peak and
we laid out a few possibilities as to
why the numbers look that way so to
remind you the things we talked about
last week were
vaccination is responsible more
vaccination fewer cases okay
some natural seasonality being
responsible even though it's not exactly
lining up with the typical flu season
that there seems to be some kind of
peaks and valleys seasonality to covid
um so many infections have gotten us
closer to herd immunity combined with
vaccination that has been suggested and
then also sort of the most nefarious
explanation is cases aren't actually
going down its reporting has become less
reliable some states maybe aren't even
being honest about cases and then at the
end of last week's segment we said well
let's wait and see if this trend
continues the trend has continued and in
the last week the numbers have dropped
even more
u.s cases per day are down now 31
relative to the delta peak the delta
peak was about
166 000 cases per day
we're now down to 114 000 cases per day
now this is still like a wild crazy
number uh but a 31 percent decline is
notable for sure
now
last week we didn't know whether deaths
were declining and what i mean by that
is that deaths tend to lag cases by
three to four weeks
and since last week we were about three
weeks into the case decline
we saw deaths level out but we just
didn't know our deaths really starting
down are they on the way down
we now have another week of data and we
can see that yes deaths are declining in
the united states
down about 11
on average from the delta peak it's not
that much but it is now clearly the
direction
the delta peak was about
1850 cases per day roughly half of the 3
900 cases i'm sorry deaths per day that
we saw
at the biggest peak of the pandemic so
far so delta peak deaths peaked at 1850
down to 1650 still a horrifying
unconscionable amount of death basically
half of a 911 every single day
but you'd rather see the numbers going
down rather than up
now one other thing that we should be
looking at
is whether what's going on in the united
states seems to follow or track what's
happening globally if cases were going
down in the u.s but up everywhere we
might say well maybe our reporting's
wrong or maybe maybe something just
doesn't make sense because we saw you
know delta came to europe and then it
came to the u.s and things seemed to
sort of move in tandem adjusting for
vaccination rates of course the u.s
delta wave down 31 from its peak
globally cases are also down about the
same about 30 percent decline in cases
globally and then very important as well
uh global deaths since the peak of delta
also declining by about
25 which you really like to see
now
within the united states
we have clearer and clearer clearer data
about the political alignment of this
delta wave we've talked about this
before and we continue to get very
interesting new data
check out this incredible graphic which
i will describe if you're not watching
today this is a plot
of covet deaths per capita
against how pro-trump or pro-biden a
state was in 2020. so if a state voted
biden over trump by 20 points it's more
pro-biden than if biden won by say 10
points okay
now if you're looking at this graph
you can see that the states with the
lowest per capita death rates as of
september 23rd 14 day average so we're
talking now in in september
you see that it's the heavy biden states
with the lowest death rate vermont
massachusetts maryland california uh to
a lesser degree
you know places that are slightly
pro-biden like illinois nevada where
biden won but not by as much
the slightly trump states are then doing
even worse in terms of covert death so
like texas for example
uh florida
and then you get into the absolute worst
states with the highest average per
capita death rates in september these
are the heaviest trump states we're
talking about alabama west virginia
mississippi etc so as we've said before
as we've seen before in the data we
don't just say it we say it if we see it
in the data
trump voting in 2020
predicts covet death rates now that
vaccines have been widely available for
some time
and that we know how you reduce the
amount of spread this is not really a
mystery and when you look at the united
states and look at the least vaccinated
states
it's essentially all red states it's
idaho
uh west virginia
wyoming
uh followed by mississippi north dakota
alabama tennessee indiana louisiana you
then get to ohio which is sort of uh you
know closer to 50 50 ohio a swing state
in many elections at 54 vaccination i
think you get the picture so the overall
story here is cases and deaths declining
in the us
cases and deaths declining globally
vaccination going up globally and in the
u.s the states that are doing the best
are the most vaccinated states which are
biden states there's really no new
information in that sense
but this is the trend as of the last few
weeks in the united states so let's
hoping continues let's hope it gets
better everywhere and we'll report back
um in another week or so and see if the
decline continues if this decline were
to continue
in six weeks we would be in amazingly
great shape caveat i said the exact same
thing
in february where we said if these
declines continued there would be no
covet in like six weeks that's rarely
the way that it goes so we'll continue
to track the numbers and see where we
end up
um is it good
that many of the most powerful federal
elected officials in the united states
are in their 80s
or even close to their 90s in some cases
now let me set this up for you
last week republican senator chuck
grassley announced he's going to be
running for re-election uh he is 88
um senate terms are six years long we're
talking 90s if he wins
joe biden is almost 79.
nancy pelosi speaker of the house is 81.
steny hoyer is 82. jim clyburn is 81.
those are the top three democrats in the
house of representatives over in the
senate the democratic leader chuck
schumer is only 70. republican leader
mitch mcconnell 79 years old senator
dianne feinstein 88 years old bernie is
80 years old patrick leahy is 81.
jim inhuff is 86. i can give you the
list fine
this is not about ageism uh republicans
have actually been using aegis tropes
against joe biden joe biden's barely
older than donald trump their big alpha
boy strong hero
joe biden's barely older republicans
have been using a lot of aegis
tropes against joe biden i have no
interest in like just a generally aegis
discussion it's more about is this
country well represented
if our elected officials skew
so dramatically older than the average
population now to some degree it makes
sense
five-year-olds contribute to the average
population but five-year-olds can't be
senators so like to some degree it would
make sense that our elected officials
are older than the average population
but we're talking about dramatically so
we've also talked before about whether
there should be an upper age limit for
president for example this isn't about
you know imposing anything some people
want an upper age limit this is more
about whether it could be argued that
the population of the united states
overall
is well served
and well represented by folks who skew
dramatically older there's a strong case
to be made that the answer is no now at
the same time we want people who are
more experienced
often times people get good at their
jobs after they've been in the job for a
while you can also have corruption and
rot which sets in when people have been
in their jobs for a while
we want people who know how these
legislative bodies work and know how to
get things done and if you increase
turnover dramatically in the house and
senate you probably increase this
revolving door of lobbyists and a number
of other problems now aside from an age
limit
you can also look at term limits but
there's quite a bit of literature in
terms of term limits which says
term limits create corruption
and they create incompetence because you
force out lots of people who could be
doing their job really well
they force people out as they become
more experienced and you create the
opportunity for moneyed interests to
interfere and swoop in
right legislation it's a complicated
issue for sure
the idea of an age limit is not unheard
of many people don't know
that canada has a maximum age for
senators there's mandatory retirement
for canadian senators at age 75.
so then we get at the end to
turnout is really low in the united
states without changing anything about
the rules term limits maximum age or any
of this stuff
if more people wanted younger elected
officials
they could get out and vote for them
support them in primaries and the
problem would sort of take care of
itself now many people would say hey
there's too many 80 year olds and my
generation's not represented and i'm
going to go out and vote but a lot of
the people who say that don't actually
go out and vote does that make sense no
but it's the situation that we have so
do we really need age limits do we
really need term limits or do we just
need more voter participation and higher
turnout from younger people who are
overwhelmingly underrepresented in the
electorate that chooses to vote it would
make sense like if you step back from
all of this
if older folks are more reliable voters
it makes sense
that you might see older folks also
overrepresented in terms of who wins so
let me know your thoughts is this
question one is is this really an issue
that elected representatives
particularly in the senate and in
general in federal government skew older
and if it is a problem
are we better off leaning on a solution
like a term limit or an age limit or
this is this really just an issue of
apathy among those who casually would
like younger representatives but aren't
actually going out and voting in
significant numbers let me know your
thoughts is it a problem and what is the
solution if so you can find me on
twitter
deepakman
one of our sponsors is curiosity stream
the only subscription streaming service
just for documentaries my girlfriend and
i have been using the curiosity stream
platform at home non-stop i can tell you
from personal experience much better
documentary selection than netflix hulu
or amazon on curiositystream i'm always
finding documentaries by the world's
best filmmakers stuff you can't find on
other streaming services last month they
added a ton of awesome new titles to the
library i just finished watching
becoming martian
about the future of the human species
and its possible path through mars but
there's documentaries on every topic
imaginable science nature history
politics if you love documentaries the
way i do you are not going to find a
better source of brand new award-winning
docs anywhere else curiosity stream is
giving my audience 25 off which means
you can subscribe for just 15 bucks a
year not a big price tag for the hours
and hours of enjoyment i know you will
get from curiositystream just go to
curiositystream.com
pacman25 the link is underneath this
video
remember that the david pakman show does
depend on viewers like you listeners
like you who sign up on our website and
become members we do an extra show every
day for our members and you can sign up
at joinpakman.com
let's get right into some uh vaccination
related controversies
more and more the question is coming up
is it time to fire unvaccinated
employees is it just time to say listen
all of this stuff about if it's over a
hundred employees then you can test
weekly although some places like fox
news are even stricter and they're
saying well no you've actually got a
test daily
is it just time to end all of it and i
want to look at a couple of articles
with you interesting article in salon by
amanda marcotte called
it's time to start firing on vaccinated
people trump fans are overdue for a
lesson in consequences the absolute
certainty of losing a job is going to
motivate a lot more people than the more
abstract risk of dying
for those readers who only peruse
headlines the impending first round of
vaccine mandate deadlines are looking
like a very scary business not for
people who are afraid of needles mind
you but those who are afraid that mass
resignations and firings and subsequent
staffing shortages shortages of
essential workers are coming
these healthcare workers would rather
get fired than get vaccinated reads a
monday morning headline at the new york
times new york hospitals face possible
mass firings as workers spurn vaccines
is another headline
rural hospitals worry they will lose
staff
because of biden's new vaccine mandate
warns an npr headline
new york may use the national guard to
replace unvaccinated health care workers
now one part of this which i'm going to
talk about in the next segment is
whether a lot of these people are lying
about quitting whether these are empty
threats
i believe that they mostly are and i'm
going to give you data to support that
in the next segment but the question
here is for the people who really are
going to refuse is it just time to start
firing them as we talked about yesterday
on the bonus show the state of new york
is the first test case of what actually
enforcing a government issued mandate
looks like monday is the deadline for
healthcare workers in new york to get
the jab or get the pink slip
as the new york times reports resistance
to vaccine mandates has so far stopped
most states from threatening to fire
unvaccinated workers but new york's
newly appointed governor is calling the
unvaccinated bluff rather than caving in
and letting them keep their jobs she is
prepared to call the national guard to
fill in the shortages left by the
upcoming fire uh firings
um
what i believe needs to happen here
is that uh we should allow these folks
to quit if they really are willing to
quit and most are not
and it should be seriously considered by
employers whether to just fire people
rather than to require the testing
you know half of unvaccinated workers in
some polls have said they'd rather quit
than get the vaccine
the real world data doesn't suggest that
that's actually the case and that most
of these folks are not actually going to
quit
now
um
one important question would be if the
mandates didn't work would they make
sense because at the end of the day what
i care about is actually getting people
vaccinated the article goes on to say
the effectiveness of mandates has been
documented outside of new york as well
as dr zeke emanuel former white house
policy advisor who works for u pen now
told fierce health care
health care systems that have actually
mandated this have retained over 99 of
their workforce that number we find
elsewhere as well the article goes on to
list over a dozen hospital systems that
have implemented vaccine mandates in
every case the fraction of workers lost
was tiny certainly well worth losing to
protect patients and the larger
community from covid similar success at
united airlines started putting workers
on leave if they don't get vaccinated 97
of employees
beat the deadline
um and then the
sort of
conclusion here is
this is precisely why vaccine mandates
are so important the absolute risk of
losing a job
is going to motivate a lot more people
than the abstract risk of dying of cohod
but for the threat to become real
it has to be real and this means it's
not enough to threaten to fire people
who won't get vaccinated employers and
governments have to follow through
hochel is right to do whatever it takes
to make sure that the unvaccinated get
their pink slips this week if leaders
back down in the face of vaccine
resistance the trumpers will double down
and continue spreading covid in a
pathetic effort to own the liberals
threats cannot be empty especially when
facing stubborn people who believe
themselves impervious to consequences
threats need to be backed up with action
it's time to start firing the
unvaccinated
i completely agree with this and you
if you want to make the case that a
business shouldn't even issue the threat
or that these should not be the battle
lines on this issue well you can have
that debate you could say actually i
think it's counterproductive to mandate
the vaccine the data says actually the
vaccine mandates work very well 97 to 99
when companies put it in place most
people aren't actually going to quit
their job
but
once you've gone to doing it
the threat can't be an empty threat
because otherwise it's not going to be
effective and uh much like
i mean you know it this is kind of like
the strict father morality that the
right often preaches which we on the
left often say
you know we want to make sure it's well
calibrated um
it can't be an empty threat and what we
are finding is that even among those
threatening to quit about the vaccine
very very few actually are let's talk
about that next
so
we talked about
should unvaccinated workers be fired and
my position there is
if the company has announced you must be
vaccinated or you can't work here
they cannot be empty threats that if if
you're saying you're going to fire
people if they're not vaccinated you've
absolutely got to do it okay
so the next question is when people when
workers say
i'll quit
do they actually do it and increasingly
the evidence is they do not let's look
at a couple articles from massachusetts
related to massachusetts state police
there are reportedly just under 2200
state troopers right now okay
let's uh call it uh 2200 it's actually
dozens of massachusetts state police
troopers have been resigning a
claim that they are resigning over the
covet vaccine mandate union says this is
an article from yesterday and this
article says the state police
association of massachusetts says dozens
of troopers have submitted their
resignation papers as a result of the
mandate the state is requiring all
executive department employees to show
proof of vaccination by the 17th or risk
losing their jobs about 20 percent of
state police employees are not
vaccinated according to the union's
attorney
a source told wbz tv on monday
only one state trooper
has told human resources they would
resign because of the vaccine mandate
they also said there are others who
spoke with hr to evaluate what their
pensions would be if they chose to
retire
the union released this statement to
date dozens of troopers have submitted
resignation paperwork some of whom plan
to to return to other departments
offering alternatives such as mask
wearing and regular testing
the state police are already critically
short staffed and acknowledged
this by the unprecedented moves which
took troopers from specialty units that
investigate homicides so you've got a
story which is the union says dozens
have submitted resignation paperwork
but then only one person has actually
said i'm resigning to human resources
another article from the boston globe
state police union says dozens of
troopers plan to resign due to vaccine
mandate
but police spokesman says only one
definitively has
so
we have to wonder
we have to wonder
is what's going on with the union the
union claiming dozens have submitted
resignation
does that actually translate to people
are actually really going to quit
so far it's one
out of
2187 massachusetts state troopers that
have actually communicated this to human
resources
i'm not saying
that the union is lying
but i'm wondering whether they've
collected resignation letters that many
don't actually intend to give to anybody
in human resources as part of a
political statement of sorts these are
good jobs you know
there's the waiting list to become a
massachusetts state trooper is very very
long and these are really good jobs are
they really going to quit over a vaccine
requirement in particular when their
pensions may be at risk
the real headline so far seems to be
fewer
than
what is it
one tenth of one percent
of troopers
have actually resisted the vaccination
requirement it's very easy to talk about
quitting a well-paying job with great
health care and retirement benefits over
a safe vaccine but it's a very different
thing to actually go and to do it so my
question is are a lot of these people
just bluffing and they're not really
going to quit
don't forget that the best way to
support the david pakman show is by
becoming a member which gives you access
to the daily bonus show the regular show
with no commercials you also get access
to our entire archive of every episode
dating back
a really long time and plenty of other
awesome membership perks go to
joinpackman.com
and use the coupon code better21 for a
huge discount join pacman.com
it is great to welcome to the program
today heidi begoshin who's a new york
city based attorney and author whose
latest book is i have nothing to hide
and 20 other myths about surveillance
and privacy uh it's really great having
you on i appreciate your time
thank you david great to be here so
let's start historically a little bit if
we can
was there
sort of a surveillance state before 9 11
and the patriot act and the bulk
surveillance that we've learned about
over the last decade or so what was
there an apparatus that predated that
and to what extent
there has always been a surveillance
apparatus in the united states and the
justification for it remains the same
it's largely based on the government's
uh theory that we need to be monitored
to protect national security
and i think what we've seen
with the events of 911 but also as the
digital age has really
taken over our lives
we've seen that surveillance apparatus
on steroids in effect
and the ways that we can be monitored
are just about as many as one can
imagine and we're seeing so many levels
of creativity to do that from spying on
children
to just invading all aspects of our
daily lives
let's talk about
some of the methods i guess because
people may not be familiar with all of
them i think
metadata is a term that many more people
now are familiar with maybe than they
used to be in this concept of well even
without the content of a phone call
uh a list of the numbers you've
interacted with can be very uh
revealing and invasive when it when it
comes to observing your activities but
can you talk a little bit about the
breadth of these techniques and
technologies that are in place
an easy way to look at the extent to
which we are monitored is to think of
the gold rush of the early days of this
nation
we're in a data rush right now
and data represents
essentially the crude oil that fuels our
digital economy
so
every time you log on we have third
party we have data aggregators which is
more than a 200 million dollar billion
dollar business in this country
so if you think of it
as your personal information
is like nuggets of gold that others want
to reap collect as much as they can
essentially without the laws
sort of like the property laws that
didn't exist when we had the early gold
rush our legislators
have not kept up with tech advances
so that um facebook for example just
announced that it was putting the pause
on developing
uh an app an instagram type app for kids
right
which really habituates not only young
kids to become
loyal users of that app but it allows
third parties to gather personal
information it may be
just what sites they visit
what preferences they have when they
purchase something online or when they
ask their parents to buy something
each of those kernels when put together
can give a really accurate profile
of our lives and you mentioned
metadata well metadata is defined very
loosely as information about information
so it's sort of
when a photo might have been taken it's
kind of embedded in all of the documents
that we get online
that when captured in large quantities
and having algorithms applied to search
for patterns in that
can really tell a lot about
who we are for example if i went to a
cancer doctor five times in one week or
an abortion provider
those
that information is then sold to others
including government agencies but
largely marketers and for-profit
entities who then design ads to target
us to buy more of a similar product
or to send us
ads about cancer treatments and
medications the problem is when you get
faulty algorithms
as we so often do
and one example was drone strikes that
this country launched in afghanistan and
other countries from 2006 on
there were flawed algorithms which means
that in that case there were lethal
consequences people who really shouldn't
have been on a terrorist watch list for
example may have been killed in drone
strikes innocent individuals right
um there's kind of two layers on which
we could talk about the security aspect
of
the surveillance state one would be
does it make us quote safer and if it
did we could then have a debate about
the trade-offs and whether that's
worthwhile so maybe we can start with
the first piece do do we know that these
techniques put in place
starting around 9 11 and going forward
does this increase safety in any
measurable way
there's been no evidence to prove that
it does increase safety and that's
really a tragedy because i think
millions
of americans
may think they're doing the right thing
by saying i have nothing to hide you can
have my data
uh but i think it was the navy war
college
issued a report years ago saying that
they had analyzed
uh so-called threats of terror
terrorists and found that the measures
put in place after 9 11 which really
cut back on a lot of our liberties uh
and certain constitutional rights that
we take for granted they found no
evidence
that it made us safer in any instance
and i think the problem is most people
don't know that it's not publicized
because
in addition to bolstering the claim that
it does make us safer what it ultimately
does is hand over information that gives
more control to those in charge and that
means less autonomy in our personal
lives and more control by others
now
if it let's talk about i have nothing to
hide maybe maybe a little bit um a few
years ago i mean that seemed pretty
reasonable to me you know my my feeling
was
yeah i i get that there may be people
who know more about me than i would
willingly give up
but i don't have any particular reason
to worry about this because i don't have
anything to hide and then i read about
over-criminalization about how sometimes
you may not think you have anything to
hide but you may inadvertently have done
something or interacted with someone who
does maybe have something to hide uh and
then all of the other pernicious ways in
which this can be used what's the best
sort of argument against that idea of i
really don't care i don't have anything
to hide
i think a fundamental argument against
that is that people need to realize the
importance that privacy has played in
this society
for example during the aids epidemic
a lot of healthcare providers hotlines
realize that in order to help quell the
spread of hiv
they would need to offer anonymous
reporting or anonymous testing
and that's true in so many other
segments so for example a woman who has
been the victim of uh spousal abuse
has to know
if she's going to come forward to seek
help that she can do so anonymously or
privately and there are different levels
of how you shield one's identity but
that pertains to whistleblowing in
government to uh encourage people to
come forward when they see malfeasance
in the institutions in which we put our
trust
so i think you have to first start it
privacy plays an essential part in
society and then you have to realize
that
if you're willing to hand over your
entire life to the government
we do so because we trust the government
and i think you know that's a wonderful
premise of which to base a democracy but
we have seen in fact that we cannot
always trust our leaders that
self-interest or other factors may
lead them to abuse our information or
very often just due to a casual mistake
my name may be confused with a similar
name
i may be mixed up with someone who did
commit a crime for example but because
of the databases
that all of our information is stored in
contains so many errors often just
sloppy data entries that uh there have
been so many cases of people caught up
in a crime that had nothing to do with
their lives and they were falsely
prosecuted it also shows that if the
government doesn't like what you say if
you're a dissident or just an outspoken
individual who criticizes a corporate
policy for example or government policy
they can target you and find just about
any reason
uh among the many antiquated laws that
are on our books to go after you
yeah that i just am i'm almost done
reading this new book the perfect police
state about china and the persecution of
the of the uyghur population
is there a spectrum in the sense of it
it seems in terms of surveillance china
is very much on one end
what's on the other end and where on
that spectrum is is the united states in
your assessment
that's an excellent question we do look
to china
as an example of the extreme
and what we as a
purported democracy would never want to
be where for example i just have to say
they have a system that is being used in
some parts of china where
uh you're under such constant
surveillance that if you jaywalk for
example or if you don't pick up after
your dog points are deducted yes and
that can you know reflect the
electricity you get the access to social
services
on the other extreme and that's a great
question because i can't really think of
a nation
um
so many of our partners in the so-called
five eyes new zealand canada the uk have
sort of rings of surveillance everywhere
it's become the norm and we're becoming
uh conditioned to just accept that but i
would imagine there are probably
countries in scandinavia or countries
maybe in latin amer south america where
the technology
in some of those countries may not be uh
sophisticated as what we have here with
our robust economy so i would imagine
that in countries without that kind of
surveillance accessibility you don't
have the digital surveillance we have
here and so where is the u.s on this
spectrum right now in your assessment
i think the us is pretty high up there
with england for example as basically
having the equivalent of these what we
call rings of steel the the
circles
of surveillance cameras closed circuit
tv but we have it built into our economy
so that
as simple as getting a cup of coffee
may have a loyalty card where they track
the numbers of coffees that you buy but
they also track more your credit card
number which is linked to other data i
think that the us is
in a race to perfect total information
awareness the collection and with the
entry of 5g
where more things will be even connected
and when they're internet connected
that provides near perfect access to our
data i wonder let me see how i can kind
of frame this up i wonder if there's a
degree of inevitability to this because
of the direction
not from a law enforcement standpoint
but from a socio-cultural technology
standpoint if there's a degree of
inevitability to some of this and i'll
give you like one example and then we
can talk about it
the entire literature now around
longevity and living longer healthier
lives and nano medicine and customized
it's mostly all premised on
having much more data not only about you
as an individual
but data about how you compare to others
and what sort of diet or supplements or
treatments or whatever the case may be
good for you specifically there's really
no way it seems to do this stuff without
many more parties having access not only
to our individual data but to
everybody's in some sense and for the
most part i mean in some kind of like
general sense a lot of that stuff sounds
kind of interesting like it would be
great to know what exact diet or what
exact preventive treatment so is there
some inevitability to this that is going
to be hard to restrict at all
i think that's absolutely right uh
first
we have convenience uh then we have the
kind of addictive quality that these
devices have and they're created in
effect just like video games to be
addictive
but there are as with all technology so
many positive benefits as you mentioned
and i think the trick is harnessing
those but also
having an educated public
that is able
to realize when
they should have the option of saying i
don't wish to share that and i think the
problem that we're having and why i
wrote this book sort of is a primer so
people could get a sense of the
different areas uh that we're impacted
by is
we need to first our legislators have to
be more educated about technology
they're
woefully behind
the advancements and that's a problem
because they can't craft laws that keep
a pace with new technologies that are
emerging daily right and new
applications so i think if we have a
program where we educate kids the first
time they learn to type on a keyboard
what the perils are and what the
benefits are
and really develop a healthy uh
course in school that parents also
participate in in digital hygiene we
would not for example let a stranger
walk into our bedroom every night and
use our toothbrush or just make
themselves at home downstairs and that's
in effect what we're doing in what young
kids are doing without that education so
i think you have to educate the public
and our leaders to the degree
that they are able to say
we need to build in privacy for example
into our devices or the software has to
be better tested before it's put on the
marketplace to ensure that adequate
privacy protections are built into their
infrastructure last thing i want to
touch on with you if someone right now
is makes it a priority uh to prevent
themselves from being tracked watched
monitored surveilled etc you google this
and you see things like turn off
microphone access for your facebook app
on your phone right very very narrow and
specific thing all the way to
don't use banks or credit cards which
for the average participant in the
modern economy is is not at all sort of
practical
to what degree is it possible to to
really not be tracked right now
regardless of how aggressively you're
willing to adopt these things or to some
degree
if you're sort of like living on the
grid it's quite difficult at this point
in time
it's super difficult one would have to
literally not use a credit card
uh stay off online searches yeah
and and and i think what's daunting to
most people and i get it is that you
know encrypting
uh for those who are reporters or
uh journalists who have to protect
confidential sources there are wonderful
measures in place that they can use it
becomes more difficult for the average
citizen to use all of those but there
are basic things like
not using the same password over
changing it using a sentence instead of
your pet's name there are basic things
that aren't that hard enabling
two-factor authentication for example
when you log into accounts uh keep down
the number of apps that you have they're
really portals unless they come directly
from the manufacturer
don't download things from online
um there are measures you can take to
reduce the amount of surveillance
i i think it's unrealistic to say you
can stop it entirely unless you go off
the grid yeah yeah uh the book is i have
nothing to hide and 20 other myths about
surveillance and privacy we've been
speaking with the book's author new york
city-based attorney heidi bergoszen such
a pleasure having you on i really
appreciate your time today
thank you david
if you value what we do at the david
pakman show remember to support us on
patreon go to patreon.com david pakman
show where you can get access to behind
the scenes videos the daily bonus show
the commercial free daily show as well
as special discounts on merch including
hats hoodies
mugs and t-shirts you can support the
show for as little as two dollars a
month check it out at patreon.com
davidpakmanshow all right i have some
extraordinarily disturbing video to play
for you this is a new interview with
again i guess former trump fraud lawyer
sydney powell you might remember that
whether she was even trump's lawyer is
like a subject of debate she was having
meetings in the oval office which
certainly signals a connection to donald
trump at the same time the trump
campaign at one point put out a
statement when she went really bonkers
saying she's working on her own
we still don't really have answers to
that but she's delivered some very
strange interviews recently uh sydney
powell has now given an interview in
which she drags supreme court justice
samuel alito into the january sixth mess
the claim that she makes is that
part of the point of the january 6th
riots
was to delay things enough that samuel
alito would be able to intervene
and somehow give the election to trump i
mean you know how these things are it's
always like well exactly how it's not
clear
uh she gave an interview on the stu
peters show this is not a program i'm
familiar with but her claim
if she's right this is the most extreme
premeditated
uh criminality
including the highest levels of power
that maybe we've ever seen
if she's making it up she probably needs
a psych evil i mean i don't you know to
be totally honest i don't really know
which of the two it is uh but let's take
a look at this here is the interview
let's listen to sydney powell the audio
quality is terrible the video quality is
terrible but let's do our best to to try
to really understand what it is she's
claiming here heard untold election case
yes we were filing a 12th amendment
constitutional challenge to the process
that the congress was about to use
under the electoral act
provisions that simply don't jive with
the 12th amendment to the united states
constitution and justice alito was our
circuit justice for that louis gomer was
the plaintiff in our lawsuit and we were
suing the vice president to follow the
12th amendment as opposed to the
electoral
count act so our electoral college act
so that was the the main point and
nancy pelosi had finagled to file an
amicus brief in it there had been inside
goings-on in congress whereby i believe
it was steve scalise and mccarthy kept
her from being an actual party she
wanted to work her way into the cases
party but somehow politically that
didn't happen but so she got noticed
when we made her filing because she
wanted to file an omega spree for had
filed and make us brief and
um then
if you're confused you i mean the the
guy on the left looks as confused as as
you and i probably are
i'll try to explain what she's talking
about in a second although again if
these are just her delusions it really
there is no explanation
you know everything broke loose and she
had to really speed up
reconvening congress to get the vote
going before justice alito might have
issued an injunction to stop it all
which is what should have happened okay
so
the gist of what she seems to be saying
here
is that
the idea of the riot was to create a
delay
so that you could get a particular
amicus or as she says amicus brief
to the supreme court
with the idea that samuel alito again
i'm trying to interpret what a crazy
person's saying but the idea is samuel
alito would be able to do something and
then
trump becomes president i guess or
something like that uh but they didn't
anticipate that nancy pelosi would so
quickly reconvene on january sixth late
really early january 7th it was kind of
the middle of the night you know
technically january 7th for much of it
and move forward and that that's what
interfered with this now
if this is true
and alito knew that this was the
expectation or you know particip said
okay it would be an incredible
conspiracy
at the absolute highest level it would
have all been premeditated if powell is
to be believed um
samuel alito should be impeached okay
it also might just be completely made up
and i'm going to be very honest with you
it almost seems more likely to me i mean
sydney powell lies all the time
and she might be making all of this up
and that's its own problem
and uh that would be one possibility now
the third possibility is she believes
this stuff but it's not true like she's
actually delusional
and if that's the case you're really
talking psych evil i mean i'm gonna be
totally frank that that's what it is so
if what she says is true it would be
grounds for impeaching samuel lolito
potentially
um if it's a lie then she's really a
crazy liar who's willing to just make up
anything
and if she believes it but it's
completely
imaginary
it's kind of a sad uh mental health sort
of uh situation
let's go to one more clip this is this
is funny because this is now the
interviewer
and i'm trying to figure out like what
does he he's trying to explain what
sydney powell i guess said and it's like
it's even more confusing let's listen up
the coup why nancy pelosi had to hurry
on january 6th according to powell on
the very day of january 6 there was a
one last-ditch legal effort that might
have stopped the certification of
disputed electoral states by the
congress a legal challenge to the
electoral count act a 130 year old law
that governs the actual electoral
college process
now this law gives both the house and
senate explicit roles in evaluating
electoral slates
even though the 12th amendment to the
constitution only gives the house a role
in choosing the president okay so this
is a part of what they've been pushing
which is
we need to only the house should be
picking the president like the senate
shouldn't even have been involved
on january 6. this is another one of
these
it's sort of like
if i misspell my name i'm not taxable
like that was a whole movement at one
it's that type of movement and the stu
peters seems to be uh sort of sort of
explaining that
the senate as we know is only involved
in choosing a vice president right so
powell brought a lawsuit to overturn
that law but only filed at the afternoon
of january 6 while a bunch of people
were trampling would have been something
to think about sooner right through the
capital in what later would be referred
to as the great insurrection yeah now
that insurrection might have played to
her advantage by delaying the final
resolution of the election but then
nancy pelosi won upped her by
reconvening congress and finishing the
tally in the middle of the night
the next day supreme court justice alito
dismissed the case but according to
powell it might have been different if
that election wasn't already over
so i guess he's just explaining he he
if if i'm understanding him correctly
my understanding of what sydney powell
is claiming is accurate it doesn't make
what sydney powell is claiming any more
true so who knows what the truth is
maybe powell increasingly thinks she's
going down and she's seeing who can who
can i take down with me if i implicate
alito maybe it helps me in some way the
bigger picture is the more we learn
the more premeditated this might have
been on january 6th allegedly involving
more and more parties whether any
individual claim is true honestly i
don't know because the people involved
are so dishonest rudy jenna ellis sydney
powell trump himself bannon
you know if these people had their way
the u.s would be a complete and total
theocracy and
authoritarian christian theocracy that's
actually what we're fighting against
here i want to address a series of
articles that people sent me
each in its own way
sort of saying trump could really be
going down for some crimes here okay now
i'm going to give you my conclusion up
front the most likely scenario is this
stuff doesn't happen but there have been
enough articles and enough people wrote
to me that i want to tell you what's
being said and you've got to look at the
language
a business insider article donald trump
could be charged with multiple election
multiple crimes over his attempts to
overturn his loss in georgia a report
says
um the article saying the report by the
brookings institution i think in
washington d.c
analyzed publicly available evidence
that showed trump and his allies
attempted to pressure georgia officials
to change the lawful outcome of the
election
a key piece of evidence is the now
infamous trump call where he wanted uh
to find 11 780 votes there's no way i
lost georgia there's no way we won by
hundreds of thousands of votes
those assertions were of course false
and the report added that trump publicly
pressured and contacted republican
officials to ask for their help
we conduct we conclude
that trump's post-election conduct in
georgia leaves him at substantial risk
of possible state charges predicated on
multiple crimes these charges
potentially include
criminal solicitation to commit fraud
election fraud intentional interference
with performance of election duties
conspiracy to commit election fraud
criminal solicitation and state rico
violations the report adds liability
could extend to allies like rudy
giuliani
another article from vanity fair says
report
trump may be hit with multiple criminal
charges over his effort to overturn the
election in georgia
this is by best levin who's done a lot
of great coverage over the years it
references the exact same report from
the brookings institution
and it mentions the request to find
eleven thousand seven hundred and eighty
votes it refers to trump pressure that
happened publicly and privately
against republican officials and it
again says trump could be hit with that
same list of charges based on the same
brookings institution report
and then lastly
from the detroit news trump faces
substantial legal risk in georgia case
think tank report says this is from that
same brookings institution report and it
lists the exact same stuff so basic
media literacy first things first all of
these articles are really one story
the brookings institution's opinion is
trump could face substantial legal
problems
um
what needs to be clarified is
if he were a normal person
i continue to see no appetite in
charging trump for what he did in
georgia should he be charged yeah yeah
could he be charged absolutely the
ongoing question is less about could or
should it happen but will it happen now
you can look at georgia and you can say
well on the one hand
republicans control basically everything
in georgia
they don't control the senate seats but
that is not involved whoa as i hit my
mic sorry that is not involved here
we're talking about state charges here
um
and republicans in georgia aren't going
to hold donald trump accountable for
anything he operates with impunity it's
infuriating but it's just not going to
happen
the other side of it is that you know
the truth is
um these elected officials in georgia
don't actually have anything to do
uh with what um uh is is happening it's
really the fulton county d.a and the
fulton county d.a
has experience with organized crime and
may not be beholden to the political
interests of state republicans in
georgia i don't know the answer my
continued belief is
trump's not going down allies might
other people might i don't see trump
going down if you disagree with me let
me know
we have a voicemail number that number
is 2192 davidp
here is eric from massachusetts don't we
we're getting away from the eric from
math stuff very soon don't worry but
he's calling back again with more i
don't even know what he's talking about
listen to this
hey david it's eric from mass hey um i
went to the doctor today and got
he won't understand any of us but it's
called the titus test t-i-t-e-r-s
and it looks like um i do have natural
immunity so
explain to me now why i need a vaccine
when i have natural immunity that does
exist
um i'm willing to go on
your show show you the paperwork and
then have you tell me why
i need
a vaccine
when i'm already immune
i mean
what
i just don't i thought see i i thought
you cared about people that was what i i
i thought originally i'm doing my best
not to jump in that's why i originally
called you seem like a guy on the level
and all this just little misinformed
don't give a [ __ ] about anybody dude you
just get a lot to care about the money
again from the
uh vaccine and alex uh
jones had a list and you were on it one
of them
mid to top
i think they were given up to 50 grand i
mean who the [ __ ] do you think you're
fooling dude
all right so listen
uh there is no evidence anybody has paid
me to promote vaccines
i don't even know why anyone would need
to pay me i just look at data and i
don't promote i just report what's out
there
we've dealt with this before
natural immunity
is not as strong as vaccinated immunity
and the strongest possible immunity is
vaccinated plus recovered from covid
that's the strongest
um so the continued
you know
this is one voicemail
there are dozens of people who leave me
voicemails like this and who send me
emails with this same type of idea this
is its own virus that is spreading
um it's sad more than anything
but fortunately you know eric from mass
is in a state of mostly vaccinated
people and that's a good thing for him
too even if he refuses to get the
vaccine joe manchin might
single-handedly up and the child tax
credit we're going to talk about it on
today's bonus show there is a pfizer
pill in testing to prevent covet 19. we
will talk about that
and john hinckley who shot president
reagan has one unconditional release we
will talk about the details and the
backstory and the decision that's been
made all on today's bonus show get
instant access immediately
thanks a lot for watching today's show i
just want to take a second to tell you
about today's sponsors
curiosity stream is the world's only
streaming service dedicated to
documentaries featuring tons of amazing
titles you won't find on any other
streaming platforms get curiosity stream
for 25
off which is just 15 bucks a year by
clicking the link right underneath this
video